Malaria is a devastating disease that affects
millions worldwide but new research has found
that the bark of two trees in Africa may be
the key to destroying, not only the malaria
parasite, but also the mosquito responsible
for transmitting the disease to humans!
Malaria is one of the most widely distributed
diseases in the world, that affected over
200 million people and led to 438,000 deaths
worldwide in 2015 alone.
The disease is caused by parasites that are
spread to humans by female Anopheles mosquitoes.
The symptoms can include fever, seizures,
and acute kidney failure.
Malaria can remain in a person’s system
for months, even years, leading to relapses.
Thus, preventing the spread of malaria can
potentially save countless lives, but how
exactly can the bark of a tree solve the problem?
Well, locals in West Africa have long used
native vegetation, including tree bark from
local trees to help treat malaria.
In 2011, an entomologist in the Republic of
Congo claimed that the bark of the Olon tree,
which is part of the citrus family, was able
to kill the mosquitoes that spread malaria,
as well as cockroaches and weevils.
Researchers created an extract from the bark
and found that not only did it kill the mosquitoes,
but it also killed the malaria parasite itself!
When scientists took a closer look, they determined
that two separate compounds were at work.
One compound called pellitorine killed mosquitoes
and another compound, dihydronitidine destroyed
the malaria parasite!
And they found a similar tree species in Mali
that also has the pellitorine.
These discoveries could the potentially save
hundreds of thousands of lives a year; however,
the pharmaceutical industry has not shown
interest in conducting clinical trials...yet.
In the meantime, researchers are hoping to
educate locals about the benefits of the extract
including encouraging them to spray puddles
with the solution to kill mosquitoes.
What if there were no mosquitoes?!
Is that possible?
Find out in this video from Trace and myself!
And what do you think?
If you could get rid of mosquitoes all together,
would you?
Or do you see a benefit in having them around?
Let us know in the comments below and keep
coming back to DNews every day of the week.